the price of groceries is through the
roof so we're gonna go to Dollar Tree to
pick up some healthy Staples to build
some balanced meals Let's Go frozen
veggies and fruit always great for easy
meals protein pancake mix you don't have
to go to a specialty store to get this
freeze-dried fruit is usually a fortune
this is one of my kids favorite snacks
my crave whole grain rice when you're in
a pinch canned tuna a high protein easy
lunch staple canned beans is an easy
thing to incorporate into breakfast
lunch or dinner
these little cheese crackers are so
delicious so addictive and they're
packed with protein cheddar popcorn is
one of my all-time favorite high fiber
snacks my kids are obsessed with these
Harvest naps and I love them too because
they're packed with eight grams of fiber
per bag this little pitted Olive snacks
are a great source of healthy fats mixed
nuts are a built-in hunger crushing
combo and perfect for the car of course
I can't go to Dollar Tree without
picking myself up one of my favorite
chocolates Whoppers healthy eating
doesn't need to be expensive so full of
more evidence-based gentle nutrition
advice